[Música]
bienvenidos a este nuevo episodio de
medio ambiente en france24 hoy
hablaremos de las maneras que están
surgiendo en américa para financiar a
los arrecifes de coral un ecosistema
fundamental para combatir la crisis
climática
por ejemplo los corales sirven como
barrera y protegen las playas del oleaje
que llega cada vez con más fuerza casi
todas las especies marinas pasan alguna
etapa de su vida en los arrecifes el
problema es que también es uno de los
ecosistemas más golpeados por el
calentamiento global el aumento de las
temperaturas del mar y la contaminación
entre otras causas han provocado la
pérdida de más de la mitad de los
arrecifes del mundo a este ritmo el 90%
se habrá perdido para el 2050 a pesar de
la gran amenaza que enfrentan estos
ecosistemas marinos son uno de los menos
financiados global coral reef fund
calcula que se necesita siete veces más
dinero del que se recibe actualmente por
eso es que la organización colombiana
provoco reeve buscan múltiples maneras
de financiación para recuperar hasta una
cuarta parte de los arrecifes en una
isla colombiano france24 viajó hasta el
lugar y aquí les contamos la historia
sembrar corales y generar dinero con
esto es lo que hace la organización
colombiana pro corrida su proyecto se
concentra en isla fuerte una exportadora
de larvas de coral mirando los patrones
de corrientes de los vientos alisios que
generan los vientos alisios y la
contracorriente del darién somos
exportadores de larvas a los arrecifes
que están en san andrés providencia y
centroamérica es decir inclusive toda la
toda la barrera arrecifal de
mesoamericana todo comienza en una
guardería en el mar luego transplantan
las partes de los corales que sobreviven
y poco a poco van creando una colonia
que favorece la conectividad de los
arrecifes el piloto es sembrar una
hectárea pero la idea es restaurar el 25
por ciento de los corales perdidos
lograrlo no es barato restaurar una
hectárea cuesta cerca de 500 mil dólares
empezaron financiando con turismo
regenerativo en el que los viajeros
pagan para sembrar coral pero en la
pandemia tuvieron que buscar otras
salidas ahora proponen desde cripto
monedas hasta tarjetas de crédito queden
pequeños porcentajes a la restauración
de estos ecosistemas marinos digamos que
es una un nuevo negocio que antes no
existía nadie sacaba dinero de la
restauración de hecho era un gasto hoy
en día es una forma de generar dinero
dentro de las comunidades otra de las
ideas son los créditos de biodiversidad
respaldado por la organización
internacional south point así las
empresas que tengan que compensar por
sus impactos ambientales pueden hacerlo
financiando la restauración de los
corales este es el primer proyecto del
cual tenemos evidencia en el caribe
principalmente y creo que es un hito
innovador en este sentido porque lo que
estamos haciendo es generar una nueva
herramienta un instrumento financiero
para la conservación una parte vital del
proyecto es enseñarle a los habitantes
locales a restaurar corales y que ellos
puedan ganar dinero con ello más allá de
financiarse con la pesca y el turismo
realmente lo que nosotros buscamos es
buscar la solución de un problema y que
eso sea rentable para todos los que
estén involucrados o sea porque
vuelvo a lo mismo si no hay un modelo
económico detrás que sea rentable pues
es muy difícil su supervivencia entonces
no nos interesa mantener esto fue
cerrado porque entonces no tendría
escalabilidad y para escalar la
restauración de ocurrir ya está
conversando con organizaciones en panamá
y méxico todo con el fin de crear más
arrecifes de coral en el mundo
la protección de estos ecosistemas
marinos también es la prioridad en el
arrecife mesoamericano que es el segundo
más grande del mundo y el mayor de todo
occidente esto después de la gran
barrera de coral de australia en el
centroamericano la organización mar font
lanza un nuevo plan de financiación en
el que los privados invierten en
proyectos que se buscan a través de una
convocatoria y que se concentra en 18
áreas protegidas costeras y marinas que
ya están priorizadas al respecto
hablamos con maria jose gonzalez
directora de smartphones ella nos
explicó en qué consiste el plan
bien lo que busca este proyecto que se
llama marcos y living best es crear un
mecanismo de finanzas mixtas para apoyar
iniciativas de mercado que generen
ingresos pero sobre todo que tengan un
impacto positivo sobre corales a través
de restauración de protección o de
reducción de amenazas a los corales y
esto es muy importante por varios
motivos primero lo vamos a estar
desarrollando en la región del arrecife
mesoamericano
que es una resiste compartido entre
cuatro países méxico belice guatemala y
honduras y segundo la idea es iniciar un
proceso financiero para promover
actividades de mercados sostenibles
positivas en la región que actualmente
no hay hay muy pocos ejemplos pero
porque invertir en el arrecife
mesoamericano así nos lo explicó maría
josé en la resiste mesoamericano es un
arrecife realmente muy importante por
varios motivos primero es el arrecife
transfronterizo más grande que hay es el
arrecife más grande del atlántico está
compartido por cuatro países es alto en
biodiversidad es resiliente a cambio
climático en muchas áreas tiene zonas en
muy buen estado de conservación no todas
por supuesto como sucede en el caribe en
el gran caribe pero hay zonas que están
en muy buen estado de conservación pero
sobre todo más de 2 millones de personas
dependen del arrecife para su sustento y
tiene un valor económico altísimo de
acuerdo con un estudio de valoración
económica que hizo que apoyó el bid el
año pasado el arrecife tiene un valor de
4.5 billones de dólares anualmente
entonces es muy importante asegurar que
permanezcan los arrecifes y los bienes y
servicios que proporcionan hasta aquí la
crónica ambiental siguen en france 24
[Música]